welcome back to good day metro sheriff
joe lombarda joining us now for today's
morning cup of joe great to see you
sheriff good morning
good morning alex good to see you in may
fallen officers were honored all around
the country
i know you took part in the ceremonies
up in northern nevada as lieutenant eric
lloyd was honored
can you talk about that a bit and the
importance of recognizing these fallen
officers
because it's important for us to
honor the families and and the families
know that we don't forget
um because this is a profession where
the ultimate sacrifice is unique
as compared to most professions and it's
important for us to remember
what people have done for their
community and and treat them like heroes
uh in the fact that they are heroes and
they
there's that selfless action
uh no fault of their own where they have
uh met harm
and it's very important for people to
remember that and for the families
especially for the kids as they grow up
because a lot of these officers have
kids that are young of age and you know
and they have to remember that for the
rest of their lives and
i think it's important for them to know
that we care
and we haven't forgotten them and it's a
that's
all part of the ceremony so it's a good
thing
yeah it means a lot to see it from all
of you and from the community too
some good news sheriff metro welcomed
recent graduates from both corrections
and police
can you talk about this recent class we
were talking about it last week it was a
big group
and those graduates were from several
countries
yeah it was a big group and i believe
there's five different
uh languages spoke amongst the group you
know besides english so it's it
it's important for people to know that
we're diversifying and
you know the workforce looks like the
community and
and the more importantly for me is is i
get some nice warm bodies
to do the lord's work community policing
and the actual police function of
putting people in
into custody that are committing crimes
and praying on the weak and
are the helpless and people that can't
defend themselves
and you know i've always talked about
that proverbial ratio two officers per
thousand residents and we went down
below that number during covid but the
showing of these numbers
and the ability to graduate folks
into the law enforcement profession is
very important
and we're getting back to that
appropriate ratio
so we can have a positive effect on
crime and a positive effect
with the community and all the community
events that we do on a regular basis
so allegiant stadium it's finally going
to open to the general public going to
hold events
starting in july with concerts how is
metro preparing for those type of events
sheriff and that new venue well the
uniqueness of the legion stadium was 65
000 people we don't have a lot of
practice with that but
um i think one of the silver linings of
covet is
it gave us an additional year to
practice and do tabletop
exercises and put the troops through the
the venue
and see all the nooks and crannies
associated with the venue and how we
address
people that are causing harm and what do
we do with people once they're in
custody
you know removing them from the pros uh
the
facility and the process that goes along
with that and
so we've had plenty of practice per se
but we're happy to put it in
in you know action as we move forward
and we're excited for it we're excited
for the raiders we're excited for
the community and we're going to be
there to provide a safe environment so
everybody can enjoy themselves
we appreciate that we're looking forward
to finally getting in there thanks so
much
if you have a question for the sheriff
send it to us on our website
8newsnow.com
morning cup of joe airs every wednesday